good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight so much drama you can't
say we're not learning a lot though
and one topic we've learned a lot about
over the last year is russia and the
reason we've learned about it is because
russia is joe biden's number one
favorite topic of conversation joe biden
can talk about russia forever meaning in
his case for up to four minutes at a
time which at this stage is joe biden's
version of a filibuster you may have
asked yourself when will joe biden ever
stop talking about russia well very soon
actually in fact he seems to be losing
his train of thought right now but don't
worry he'll be back to it
russia is a very comfortable topic for
joe biden he enjoys talking about it
much more than talking about say
inflation or crime or fentanyl deaths or
about how half the population of haiti
appears to be showing up in florida in
leaky boats
those subjects may interest you since
you live in this country but not joe
biden despite appearances biden doesn't
actually live here in his head joe biden
is floating high above the sea of azov
swooping in over southeastern ukraine
like a botox superhero just to make sure
everything's okay with his little
buddies the ukrainians joe biden to
protect her that way but he's also at
the same time a scholar and a teacher
not a credentialed educator like the
doctor he's married to joe biden didn't
go to community college in delaware for
a doctorate in diversity studies he's
just a civilian but biden can still
lecture with the best of him if you
signed up for his intro to russia is bad
class this semester you will not be
disappointed professor biden knows that
material cold so what have we learned so
far well first and foremost russia is
bad that's the name of the course it's
the entire syllabus actually it may be
the only fact you will come away with
after months of heavy coursework russia
is bad learn that and you will ace the
exam
now to be clear we're talking about
russia here we're not talking about the
soviet union there's a difference and
joe biden's been around long enough to
know what that difference is he's seen
it firsthand the soviets wanted peace
joe biden told us that repeatedly in the
70s and 80s russia by contrast just
wants war
the russians are warlike people it's
inherent russians are driven by
bloodlust they have tiny brains their
breath smells like herring they're
always drunk often on aftershave or
household cleaning products
on sunday mornings when good people are
still asleep at home with their families
your average russian will still be
lurking through the dark streets
leering through bloodshot eyes trying to
subvert somebody else's democracy or
conquer a peace-loving neighbor that's
just who russians are it's what they do
but if there's one thing you absolutely
must know about russia if you're going
to navigate this world
that thing is that on february 16 2022
vladimir putin is going to invade our
closest ally in the world ukraine so
write that down february 16th 2022
ukraine invasion begins that's the day
joe biden has been very clear about that
so the intel agencies and of course
there's stenographers in the news media
as politico put it quote russia will
start a physical assault on ukraine as
soon as february 16th multiple u.s
officials confirmed
a physical assault but this won't be
your typical physical assault like the
kind you've experienced in the new york
city subway no
according to politico this physical
assault quote could be preceded by a
barrage of missile strikes and cyber
attacks
so these aren't just gang members
they're
russians the daily mail confirmed
politico's reporting quote putin has
decided to invade ukraine on wednesday
read the headline brits and americans
told to get out now
that same day the mirror in london let
us know they had seen vladimir putin's
planning documents and operations snuff
out ukrainian democracy was already in
motion quote
russian invasion of ukraine set for 3
a.m tomorrow with missiles and tank
attack
so february 16 2022 was definitely the
day the music was going to die in
ukraine everybody knew that
but weirdly nobody thought to tell the
president of ukraine who is an obedient
puppet of the biden state department you
might think would have heard the news
but no he hadn't he was baffled by it
he said this quote we are told that
february 16th will be the day of the
attack
we will make it a day of unity the
relevant decree has already been signed
on this day we will hang national flags
where blue and yellow ribbons and show
the world our unity that was president
zielinski
now keep in mind that in addition to
being a puppet of the biden
administration president zilinski of
ukraine was also at one point a
low-grade comic of some kind so he was
kidding that was a joke but in the
american news media there are no jokes
humor has been banned for several years
now in fact at this point you're more
likely to hear a joke on a russian news
broadcast than on american television
which is pretty amazing if you think
about it things have changed
in any case the readers
of teleprompter on our tv channels did
not get this joke at all so here's the
coverage they produced this is cnn
breaking news we're back with more on
the breaking news just out of ukraine
president zielinski saying ukraine has
been informed that this wednesday the
16th will be the day of the attack
ukraine's president zielenski addressing
his nation today about reports
intelligence picked up that actual date
for an attack of wednesday telling them
that he is told that february 16th will
be the day of the attack uh president
zielinski saying that
his government has been told that
february 16th will be the day of a
possible attack today defiant ukrainians
celebrated a day of unity there had been
reports and intelligence warnings that
today february 16th might be the day of
the invasion of course that's up to
vladimir putin
will ukraine be ready
oh if that was up to vladimir putin
they didn't get it was a joke
so it put us in a very weird position
where suddenly we were being lectured on
humor by eastern europeans
think about that for a minute zilinski's
staff issued a statement explaining that
actually he was kidding so some news
outlets had to update the reporting but
they were clearly annoyed with zelinski
quote ukrainian leader makes confusing
joke about russian invasion
new york magazine
but here's the funniest part of all
there was no invasion
february 16 2022 was
yesterday nothing happened vladimir
putin did not invade ukraine
now if joe biden noticed the lack of an
invasion he didn't acknowledge that he
didn't say a word today he was back on
television assuring us once again the
invasion's coming
how high is the threat of a russian
invasion right now
it's very high
why it's very hit because they have not
they have not moved any of their church
out they've moved more troops in number
one number two
they have reason to believe that they
are
engaged in a false flag operation they
have an excuse to go in
every indication we have is they're
prepared to go into train attack ukraine
are you gonna call putin i'm not calling
food i have no plans to call putin right
now
so here's a guy who's literally wearing
a mask outside assuring us that he's
sane and on the ball enough to know
when putin is going to invade ukraine
but of course he's gotten it wrong
what's going on here
well the most obvious explanation is the
most
it's the most obvious one
daughtering old joe biden who even
before he was senile was widely
considered a [ __ ] in washington has
been played by vladimir putin who may be
evil but definitely is not stupid
if putin bluffed an invasion of ukraine
to make biden look ridiculous
it worked
maybe there was something else going on
maybe putin still plans to invade
ukraine it's hard to know but as you
just heard joe biden doesn't know
because he refuses to talk to the
russians the russians are too immoral
for joe biden
that's saying a lot coming from a former
credit card lobbyist who helped run
america's most corrupt state
but according to joe biden vladimir
putin is not someone you can ever talk
to because he put bounties on the lives
of american troops in afghanistan how
does joe biden know that happened well
he got it from the very same people who
spent all last month telling us that
putin was going to invade ukraine on
february 16th here they are
new report says that russia offered
afghan militants bounties to kill u.s
soldiers the administration's
non-reaction cnn matching the reporting
cited a source asserting that the cash
rewards did lead to coalition casualties
not so long ago in a land not so far
away there was a republican party that
would have confronted russia for putting
bounties on the heads of u.s soldiers to
say nothing of putting bounties on
american troops
i mean he has still yet to say anything
as the president united states about
bounties on american troops
so the most discredited people in the
world weighing in with total certainty
on the most important topics if you were
to sum up the moment we're living in
that's how you'd describe it everything
that has told you turned out to be
untrue they were lying why were they
lying about that well of course to keep
us in afghanistan forever why would they
want to do that you ask we weren't
achieving anything obviously the second
we left the taliban took over and became
one of the best armed militaries in the
entire region so we were doing wasn't
working but they didn't want us to leave
in fact they're willing to lie to keep
us there
why
well we don't have any special intel but
we're thinking maybe the defense
industry profligate campaign donors may
have had something to do with it here's
senator richard blumenthal of
connecticut explaining that actually
ukraine needs a lot more lethal weapons
from raytheon watch i was so deeply
impressed with how resolute and
determined people of ukraine are they
are courageous they are steadfast and
they're going to fight in the streets
their neighborhoods the fields if we
give them the arms that they need and
that's why i've also urged the javelin
missiles and the stinger missile to
combat their tanks and their aircraft
so that guy who lied about his own war
service is pretty excited to the thought
of ukrainians fighting and dying in the
streets
these people are so ghoulish and of
course they're promoting war
not to maintain the democracy that is
ukraine ukraine is not a democracy it
has never been a democracy in its
history and it's not now
it's a client state of the biden
administration it's a place in which
opposition media and opposition
political candidates are completely shut
down by the government is not a
democracy at all and it's insulting they
would suggest otherwise but people like
that
and many people in washington are
pushing ukraine toward war so we're
sending them weapons and then making it
very easy for them to use them
they told us now for months that any
pre-emptive attack by ukraine
actually isn't real if you see ukraine
using these weapons no
says tony blanken
that's not aggression it's a false flag
attack by
russia
russia plans to manufacture a pretext
for its attack
this could be a violent event that
russia will bring on ukraine or an
outrageous accusation that russia will
level against the ukrainian government
we don't know exactly the form it will
take
it could be a fabricated so-called
terrorist bombing inside russia
the invented discovery of a mass grave
a staged drone strike against civilians
or a fake
even a real
attack using chemical weapons
so they're gonna use chemical weapons
but it won't actually be them it'll be
those diabolical russians
drunk on aftershave once again there is
zero evidence that any of this is true
this is clearly some sort of intel op
that's being filtered through the state
department and the media
but yet for months now they told us
russia is definitely going to
manufacture a pretext for a ukraine
invasion so finally a lone ap reporter
bravely asked how do you know this and
they immediately accused him of working
for putin
he's pretty much the only reporter who
asked a question like that and there's a
depressing irony to that matt tabby put
it very nicely this morning in a piece
on substance quote a big reason we're
supposed to be an improvement over
putin's russia tayibi wrote is that we
don't use the news media as an
instrument of information warfare at
least russian reporters don't have much
choice in being conscripted for this
duty
what's the excuse of westerners who
broadcast cia gibberish on command
well that's a very good question and the
answer is they have no excuse
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else